in this episode i interviewed four
people who have had experiences with the
carnivore diet
this episode makes me quite nervous
because these stories don't sound
believable
even coming from someone who's spoken
about my lion diet and the carnivore
diet i straight up would not believe
these stories if i hadn't lived an
experience that was also unbelievable
part of me wants to drop the whole diet
thing and just stick with my podcast the
other types of episodes i never wanted
to be a diet person and i certainly did
not want to be a diet person who talks
about an all meat diet however i've seen
what doing what you could call an all
meat type of elimination diet can do for
people
it seems to be able to heal your gut
like an elemental diet it's the only
elimination diet that allows you to
thrive on one food and then ideally it
allows you to reintroduce other foods
back in once your gut is healed i have
information about the diet on facebook
for free and scattered about my website
anyway i interviewed four individuals
that have had insane transformations on
a carnivore diet hear their stories take
them in whatever way you want to it
sounds insane but it fixed me and once
you have your joints disintegrate you're
pretty much willing to try anything
in a
more fun note this episode is brought to
you by carnivore crisps
i thought this was an appropriate
sponsor for the episode
i'm actually pre-recording this intro
and this ad because i didn't want to eat
all of these i didn't want to wait to
eat all these and i didn't want to save
one to show you guys for when the ad
airs these are carnivore crisps and the
ingredients are literally meat and salt
and they taste like chips
coming from someone who hasn't had chips
since 2016. seriously though these are
awesome go to carnivorecrisps.com
and enter code mp for 10 off although
that code doesn't work on their
subscription these are so good andre
likes the chicken skins but my favorite
is brisket hands down and the rib eye
they also have chicken and fish and
other cuts of beef i cannot recommend
these enough they're paying me for an ad
but i've honestly spent more money
buying them than i've made check them
out i would live off of these things if
i could carnivorecrisps.com
codemp
also linked below
and here's the episode it's crazy but
true and this may be the last time i
really focus on this diet thing for a
while because it's really hard i cried
after speaking with three of these
people anyway
here it is
[Music]
brett lloyd welcome to my podcast
it's a pleasure to be here michaela i
appreciate this opportunity so first off
how long have you been on
a carnivore diet
this is my 939th day of only consuming
animal protein and fat so what is that
and i've had sorry go ahead i've had
zero cheat days and i've had zero cheat
days in that time wow
uh so first off i guess what does that
diet look like for you
well initially the first five months it
was a variety of meats but i always made
sure to have at least two meats with
every meal because in my research on how
to do this way of eating
the reasons why people who failed
they they kept saying they would get
tired of just eating meat and i could
intellectually understand that
and
after thinking about it a while i
realized i'd never had a meal in my life
that bacon was on the plate that i
didn't enjoy in some fashion now it
wasn't like bacon was always my favorite
meat
but i just came to that realization and
so i made it a point i would always have
two types of meat with every meal and
one of those would always be bacon
so the first five months it was a
variety of meats with bacon a lot of
steak eggs and bacon
pork shoulder roasting bacon you can fix
bacon with everything and it tastes good
but in december of 2018 i discovered
that lean ground beef truly satisfies me
90 10 or 93 7 it just satisfies me to
the core of my being so i've had nothing
but lean ground beef and bacon since
then without fail and i've loved every
bite of every meal every day
that's that's good to hear uh that takes
quite a bit of well let's go a bit into
a background of why you started the diet
so what were you
suffering with give me a brief history
of your health issues
i suffered from chronic severe
depression anxiety and insomnia for over
40 years of my life
and uh i've i heard your dad say that he
eliminated his symptoms you've
eliminated jurors and i was going to try
it one way or another because i had
great belief in what you all were
offering
and
you all were telling the truth because
it's worked i've not i had lost my
depression symptoms on the 24th day i
lost the anxiety symptoms totally after
five months
and after 10 months the insomnia
symptoms were completely resolved
that's like absurdly similar to what
happened to me
which was it was around the same period
it was depression like i was
crying
you know that do me do me depression and
at that point it was just i wasn't as
depressed as i had been and i was
already off meds but it was around
three and a half weeks in that the
depression got a
went away and then it took five months
till the anxiety went away um were you
on like what did what did
not to get into like how horrible it is
because i am aware but what did the what
did depression and anxiety look like for
you for me i was an angry depressed
person
i had extreme dissatisfaction with
everything in my life nothing was ever
good enough i was never good enough
i got very deluded as time went on you
know michaela if i just had this coffee
cup everything in my life would be so
much better
and then at great expense and
aggravation to members of my family we'd
get this coffee cup
and 10 minutes after getting it i would
find a hundred things that were wrong
with it and why it was a piece of crap
and why my life just had to continue on
being awful
um
so
that was it in a nutshell i used to
describe it imagine if you could
living with a 50-pound anvil on your
head every day
it's always weighing you down it makes
everything you do think say so much
harder and it's grinding on you all day
long and you go to bed with it knowing
it's going to be there waiting on you in
the morning
that's what depression was like
did you end up were you did you end up
medicated for depression severely
medicated i started taking pro i was
first diagnosed in 1990
river park
hospital psychiatric hospital in
huntington west virginia i was put on
prozac for a time
i couldn't afford to keep on it at that
time but then was later told in 1995 was
told if i didn't start taking meds my
life was going to become very
uncomfortable
and i just
1995 i started taking prozac and i took
it for over 23 years but as time went on
i got worse
i got more more obese uh in 2007 i had a
classic textbook nervous breakdown
uh went without sleeping for
too long it started my my diagnosis got
improved to or adjusted to major
depression with psychotic features
because when you hear children playing
in the yard and you're the only one home
that's not good
and all those medications followed the
same route i would be better for a time
and then
all hell would happen again you know for
no reason my mood would crater or crash
or sometimes we figured out sometimes
for no reason around a full moon
my mood would crater and crash
uh it was because you well said it's a
nightmare i don't need to give the
details to you but that's what i went
through i took my meds compliantly
because i had i'd worked in the psych
field in my 20s
and uh one of the reasons for chronic
recidivism in psych hospitals is people
not taking their medicines as prescribed
and i didn't want to be that guy i went
to my appointments i followed the
directions i did everything i was told
to do and i just got worse
yeah yeah so what was it like
did you end up coming off of your
medication after
the diet started working i was actually
off the medications before the diet um
my story's a little weird in this aspect
there's a cannabis component to it all
right in
january 2015 i weigh 299 pounds was on
seven different meds psych meds
and
and my psychiatrist the last one i'll
ever have not named georgia eid said uh
you need to seriously consider
electroshock therapy and or long-term
hospitalization
and i had seen ect patients after their
therapy immediately after their therapy
and there was no way i was going to let
that happen to me
and i was very much afraid that if i
committed myself i might go in and never
come out
uh but a friend of mine who works with
me on a music project
was watching all this and one day she's
like have you ever thought about medical
marijuana
and
as a musician it was always around but i
had a bad experience with it when i was
young so i never touched it anymore
and
you know i knew about what was going on
in colorado and oregon and elsewhere and
i did a little reading and saw some
anecdotal evidence
similar to what we see in the carnivore
community people having symptom relief
and my wife and i were at this point
what is there left to try what do we
have to lose
long story short michaela i found out
that the cannabis treated my symptoms
didn't heal me it treated the symptoms
successfully
unlike any of the psych meds i ever took
my anxiety would flatline go to nothing
my mood would come up
i could i could behave in a socially
appropriate manner
and i could almost accurately perceive
my environment one of the worst things
about my depression was
you might say or my wife would say oh
it's going to be a beautiful day
but my illness would twist that
and never in my favor to where what i
honestly heard with my ears and my head
was
yes it's going to be another beautiful
day
and because i love my wife honey what's
wrong
well what do you mean what's wrong i
just so you can imagine the conflict
that would arise from just not being
able to communicate nobody could i
couldn't understand what people were
trying to convey to me and they couldn't
understand me at all
i hope that answers your question
i've always wondered because i i had
very severe depression very severe
depression and i had a lot of similar
symptoms to you where i couldn't
accurately
i didn't understand what was going
around
on around me um
in a way that i just wasn't interpreting
things correctly the way peop the way i
heard things the way i saw things i
wasn't seeing color properly so
everything kind of looked gray
right like um it just sucked the joy out
of everything right even the joy you
hear in people's voices it was really
bad so
what you're describing seems similar to
me i also had um i was angry really
volatile and really angry in ways that i
couldn't control
um
and i've always wondered if part of that
was the medication i was on exacerbating
some parts of it because i remember i
was put on medication when i was really
little i was like 12. and so i remember
before that that i was angry
um
so i i just thought that maybe
being on antidepressants because they
did like bump me up a little bit at
least at the beginning you know and then
i got worse like you but they did bump
me up but i still had that volatility do
you think that
being on meds changed the depression at
all or do you think that's what the
depression was like
i i
i can look back i was voted class grouch
for my graduating class i started
experiencing symptoms looking back over
my shoulder the sleep disruptions and
the mood
cratering started around age 15 so and i
didn't start meds until you know 1990.
so i i was the angry depressed person
before
the meds i i do believe the meds
exacerbated things though i think
looking back they did make everything
worse i think they magnified and and
amplified things rather than minimizing
or
throwing a blanket over them as
advertised
okay that's okay that that helps me out
because like i said i can't remember
very well before them but i do remember
being angry
and and thinking as a kid
why am i so angry that's an unreasonable
response and then soon soon after that i
was diagnosed with like severe
depression and put on medication and
then i remember getting better
and then i got worse
right and now i know after stopping
because i had i had a really bad time
coming off of them um
now i know that
i think that they made it worse later
even though they initially helped and i
think that's something i've been trying
to tell people because a lot of people
go on and they go oh this is life-saving
initially and then they they take it for
like 10 or 15 years and they can't get
off of it so what was your experience
like
so you switched to to medical marijuana
was that did that switch help oh
absolutely it made me more socially
acceptable depression made me i mean i i
couldn't carry on a conversa an
appropriate conversation
with anybody outside of my home
literally
uh you know
taking me to a social gathering was a
big risk because you just i never knew
it wasn't that i was intentionally
planning on
deciding to be inappropriate i just was
because i couldn't interpret things
correctly
by the end of 2015 i was off all the the
the anti-psychotics and antidepressants
that was pretty easy but then
i
did the research i was one of those i
didn't just take my medicine i knew what
the side effects were what the titration
schedule was i learned it all because i
didn't want to be
that non-compliant ignorant person
and uh and of course i still didn't know
what i didn't know them but by the end
of 2015 i was off off the antipsychotics
the antidepressants by the end of 2016 i
was off the ativan which i was on for
eight and a half bloody years
and that was really tough to come off of
and interestingly enough you'll
appreciate this after what you and been
through with your dad recently
the day after i took my last
1 8 of a milligram of adivan
i came down with vertigo for the first
time in my life
yeah that lasted for the next three
months and i have no doubt that that was
tied to the benzodiazepine withdrawal
but then at the end of 2017 i was off i
was still taking traciton that was my
sleep medicine i went to sleep on
tracidome for over eight years and i
stopped taking that in 2017. i haven't
had any pharmaceutical medication say
for one round of antibiotics when i had
an upper respiratory infection in
november of 2018 i've not had any pills
of any kind and god willing i never will
again
good for you thank you and good for you
for coming off of them properly
like
i had no idea all the doctors i'd been
to and there were a ton of doctors all
the doctors i'd been to had said
the medications i was on
were basically
safe right
i mean i took at one point i took
oxycontin
and even then i came off of it too
quickly but um the oxycontin was for
pain and at least people are aware that
that causes
withdrawal so when it happens you're
like oh i'm in opiate withdrawal and you
know of that but i had absolutely no
idea that you had to titrate down psych
meds
like i thought well if the depression
isn't there then you can just stop
taking it but that is not true
antidepressant withdrawal syndrome is a
very real thing and and i had this this
same psychiatrist
pulled the biggest bonehead move in life
and if he wasn't so well connected i
would have sued him out of existence
he made me go from i took prozac for 23
years well the last six months i was on
psych meds he decided that i should take
latuta and he made me go cold turkey
from the prozac straight to the latute
tudor said i wouldn't have any problems
needless to say that was not what
happened
that was a horror show imagine if you
will mikayla what it might feel like if
somebody took a warm washcloth and
rubbed it directly onto your brain
i had that kind of sensation for months
because of that charade
that's why i don't there's very few
physicians on planet earth right now
that i would let give me the first bit
of medical advice it's
i've had a similar experience and have
similar feelings towards the medical
profession that you've you verbalized
over the last few years
not too much yeah
yeah i think if you're put on seven
medications and then switched around and
people are like yeah no all the symptoms
you're experiencing are in your head and
you get told that for long enough then
most people would have similar
a similar response
as us
okay do i have any more questions for
you so you went on the diet and you we
went to carnivore and it was fairly
loose compared to what i did
at the beginning and even on that looser
version your depression went away within
the first three and a half weeks that's
correct absolutely
uh at that time
eggs stopped being satisfying after the
first couple of weeks and my wife would
buy these big chunks of london broil and
cut them up into smaller steaks so i i
had a bunch of those with bacon
uh a lot of pork because pork was
affordable like cheaper
at that time we and we didn't know what
we were doing yet
as far as buying meat etc um but yeah i
i never there was never a meal that i
didn't feel like boy this is delicious
you know how it is every bite's just so
good
um
but once i discovered the lean ground
beef and bacon and everything changed
even more for the better it was like i
went into turbo mode
as far as healing and my mood and
everything just got dramatically better
because i was satisfied i am satisfied
after every meal like you wouldn't
believe well yeah you would believe it
yeah well it helps to not be
completely insane yes it does i am a big
advocate of sanity and that's why i tell
people
there's no taste there's no flavor
there's no texture there's no social
setting in life
worth me risking my sanity for
and that's why you know i i applaud your
willingness to want to try to add things
back
i'm never going to try to add things
back because it's just not worth the
risk to me
because there's no yeah if i lose my
sanity especially i've been watching you
for a while gal
you had that issue there where your
happiness kind of went away you talked
about well i kind of got it back it's
like being happy like a wolf and i paid
attention to that
and i thought you know there's just
nothing i miss badly enough
to want to ever risk it
i think maybe being sick for 40 years
might be the difference i don't know
well i was sick for 25. yes you know 40.
but that that it was a long time um the
difference was i was only eating beef
and if you only eat beef
things get kind of tiresome i can
understand that i can intellectually
understand it very much but i did try
and reintroduce things and part of the
reason i wanted to reintroduce things is
because i have an audience and
my theory behind this is that
some people are extremely damaged and
that medication can exacerbate that and
i kind of wanted to test out to see if
is this damage that people can heal from
and from my experience like i couldn't
drink tea for a long time and i can
drink tea now and it doesn't bother me
and i mean it took me a number of years
to have of having no depression to even
risk that
but i have wanted to do some testing out
to see if this is
these are things you can heal from plus
in order to get more people interested
in trying it's more of an encouraging
story to say
you know what i did only eat beef for
two years and then i had beef and fish
and then i had beef and fish and chicken
and now i have tea as well sure so this
isn't necessarily for the rest of your
life because it can turn people off
although once
if you are chronically ill and then you
heal generally people don't care once
they're at that point right they're like
i'll do it forever as long as i'm
healthy but getting people to try it
is
it's tricky especially if you're already
like i'm surprised you managed to jump i
guess you were at the end of your rope
and you're like i'll try anything but
people who are depressed specifically
depressed and have that
that don't just don't trust anything
anybody says those are the people who
need this kind of thing the most that
was me
and um it's hard to
convince
those people because you get told like
you said here's a mug just be happier or
exercise more or eat healthier whatever
that means um take a walk get pretty
tired of it take a walk in the sun
you'll feel better
i had a priest tell me that once and
that immediately said well no
in your seminary experience they didn't
cover the human psychology at all did
they doc
uh
professor
it's really
i agree with what you're saying i in my
coaching i do coaching with meet rx and
and i see that a lot
and because of my experience mostly the
folks with depression and anxiety issues
are the clients i get
and uh it really is a challenge
between dealing with those who are still
listening to their illness
but want to get better and they they see
a little bit of hope and and trying to
get them to stop listening to their
illness and just follow the directions
can be quite a challenge
but you're right it to try to make it
more palatable is is a good thing i
agree with that completely
because it does frighten folks it does
frighten people just me forever i kind
of remember
they told me the doctor until i asked
him when about 43 i said do you ever see
a day when i might not have to take this
prozac again
and he said you'll have to take it for
the rest of your life and it was like it
was like a
prison sentence
that was what it felt like and i could
understand how people oh i can't eat any
any anything but meat for the rest of my
days
i get that
yeah
plus it's new like the diet's so new
that we're not we don't really know
about what what the human body is
capable of i like there's things i know
that i can i'm not going to be able to
eat because i'm really sensitive
psychiatrically autoimmune wise like i'm
super sensitive and unless i can solve
the underlying problem
there are things i'm not going to be
able to eat but i don't know that in
a number of years i won't be able to eat
a more varied diet given the fact i can
now i can have some spices i usually
keep it pretty simple because i feel
best with like lamb and beef
um but if i have chicken with spices now
i can do that without going insane which
is a huge
being able to do anything and not go
insane is a big thumbs up dear i i i
appreciate that so much what you just
said
yeah i i've got family members who
unfortunately aren't who are suffering
from mental illness and unfortunately
aren't willing to to give this a try and
just like hey you can't beat sanity i'm
telling you you need to take it up you
need to do whatever you can to take up
sanity it's your lifelong vocation it's
really worth it
yeah i agree well brad thanks for coming
on uh where can people find you you can
find me on instagram at
thankful.carnivore
you can also find me on twitter at
stickman bleeding that's
s-t-i-c-k-m-a-n-b-l-e-e-d-i-n
do not add a g and uh
have any questions or
want to find out more about the carnival
way of eating i answer all direct
messages
every one of them every day
be happy to help you
great well thanks very much for coming
on i'm so glad you're feeling better you
look great thank you michaela back at
you thank you for what you do
[Music]
rebecca farmer welcome to my podcast
thank you for having me i'm so excited
to be here
i haven't come across very many people
who i can say were
like nearing or sicker than me there are
definitely people out there obviously
but i just don't come across them
especially ones that have found
the carnivore diet but you are certainly
up there so could we start off by you
giving a brief background about who you
are and
how sick you were like that story yeah
yeah i'll make it as brief as possible
um
i've been
malnourished since sixth grade
was the first sign of malnourishment
when i was
diagnosed with osteoporosis
came down i had very severe mood
disorders in seventh grade i was
constantly getting sick failure to
thrive i was diagnosed with multiple
doctors with failure to thrive which is
really alarming
um just throwing antibiotics at me all
the time
and in seventh grade i had
narcolepsy adhd ocd insomnia depression
and i wasn't just diagnosed with these i
was
seriously suffering
big time so they put me on adderall
clonazepam and ambien
and they were like yeah you can take
these long term no problem so i stayed
on those for 13 years
near the end of high school i was rushed
to the emergency room
i thought i was having a heart attack
they diagnosed me with costco chondritis
which is inflammation of the chest
tissue
um pumped me with morphine said go home
and take care of your anxiety
um
in 2017 my
central nervous system crashed
i think that it was
the last straw of my gut because i had
just finished wisdom teeth removal
surgery and i took the opioids and
antibiotics that they give you
um and i think it just broke my gut and
i was literally
having crippling suffocation and anxiety
attacks like i
i would be so tense i couldn't even
unclean unclench my fists i couldn't
breathe i was begging my parents and my
fiance to come over to massage me
because i didn't know what to do i was
going to the emergency room all the time
so that's when i decided i've got to get
off of these meds
and see new doctors because i they
weren't working
um so
i was diagnosed with chronic lyme
disease and a plethora of autoimmune
diseases at that time
and honestly it was a relief because
it's like at least it's they're not
calling it anxiety anymore
i did
a lot of the things with the lyme
disease doctors
but i walked away from them because it
wasn't sustainable it's not sustainable
to do
spend thousands of dollars on iv
treatments you know every week for the
rest of your life and i did ozone
therapy in new york city i got prp
um and it didn't help i continued to get
worse and worse
so i started doing a stricter version of
the ketogenic diet like a four to one
fat to protein ratio
to help with non-epileptic seizures that
i was having and that helped it got me
out of bed
um i was no longer bed bound felt like i
could drive
um
and but i kept getting worse and so i
started to lose rapid amounts of weight
and the doctors were like well yeah you
are you're on a ketogenic diet that's
what it's for and i'm like no like
i was counting my calories that's when i
started counting and i was up to 6 000
calories per day
this is when i came up with my
keto ice cream recipe dairy free because
it was like what's the easiest thing
that i can eat like with without
stopping
um i was still losing weight so
that was hell and i was misdiagnosed
with an eating disorder more times than
i can count
even by my functional medicine doctors
and
i was held against my will in an eating
disorder unit
um my parents were so concerned about me
and they said if you check yourself out
then
you won't have a house to come back to
um
and that was horrendous so i came out of
there with even more autoimmune issues
my epstein bar was
crazy
um i didn't poop for an entire month
and
i
started losing weight again
um so i gained 15 pounds in there and i
just started flying off so that's when i
was finally diagnosed with c diff
a chronic seeded infection
yeah yeah and i know you can relate to
this and i wonder you know if your
symptoms were similar but
i was i just thought it was normal to
have diarrhea all the time and having
like mucus in my stools
i was dealing with so much i didn't even
talk about it
um
but
yeah so i was resistant to
13 rounds of antibiotics and then i was
approved to have a fecal transplant i
had three fegal transplants and still
had c diff
so this brings me to may of 2019
where i'm 69 pounds is my last recorded
lowest weight
and
the they're holding me in isolation i'm
literally asking them to treat me with
an eating disorder because i couldn't
refeed
um i was having severe ulcerative
colitis it was causing me to
involuntarily throw up gastroparesis i
have compressed scleroderma like i was a
wreck
hypoglycemia all the time
and so they were sending up you know 75
carbohydrates throughout the day
and
i spoke with the dietitian privately
and i said
you've got to let me eat only meat
and i i mean she listened i talked to
her for like 20 minutes
so she
allowed me to be in direct contact with
the doctor at the hospital or i'm sorry
not the doctor the the chef
in the kitchen at the hospital without
the doctor knowing
um and he was sending up multiple
entrees of fish
hard-boiled eggs
meat red meat and butter
um
and
my blood sugars immediately stabilized
no more glucagon shots i stopped
involuntarily throwing up
and i was able to gain four pounds in
that emergency room
so at the end of that um it was a week
later and the doctor tells me okay we
can't hold do any more
she found out what i was doing she said
go home and do your weird all meat diet
and i've never looked back
oh man that is brutal
okay why did you even come to the
conclusion to try
the meat diet danny vega was the first
person to plant the seed um it was when
i was
first working with the functional
medicine doctors and i found out i had a
bunch of autoimmune stuff going on so i
got on the phone with them and he said
you know there's this thing called
carnivore that
can actually
work for autoimmune but i i didn't
listen because i was addicted to my keto
foods
um and i thought that that's what i was
supposed to do because it works you know
it got me out of bed it was helping with
the seizures
um
so i didn't and i i tried all
beef salt and water
eight times and i felt worse each time
did you try that when you had c diff
oh yeah
yeah yeah i just felt worse
and i don't know if it was i'm sure it
had something to do with feeling
restricted but
my energy was horrible my mood didn't
improve
um
and so i just discounted it i was like
this is not for me
but i never tried it with variety i
never made it my own so when i was in
that when i came back from that hospital
room i was like i'm gonna use my
critical thinking
and do this in a way that makes it
sustainable for me i had to get out of
the support groups on facebook which are
awesome they're awesome but
i had to get out of my own head you know
this perfectionism mindset
yeah that's fair enough um what what do
you what did you end up eating
on the so you you stayed on the
carnivore diet what exactly did you eat
that was mostly fatty lamb
um okay we should get into this a bit
yeah fatty lamb i did better i still do
better with fatty lamb than beef
i couldn't eat steak for like five
months it was too filling and it spiked
my blood sugar
but yeah i ate egg yolks bone marrow
beef suet fatty lamb i was making broth
with chicken feet and pig ears
i was making air fried fish skins which
are really good
but they do stink up your house if you
don't like the small fish
um
and
yeah that's it for the most part i was
making carnivore cheesecake and i
allowed myself to eat dairy for the
first two months because i needed
hyperpalatable things i needed to keep
gaining weight and it was so hard for me
to eat more than
a fourth of a steak so
i really um i made things hyperpalatable
and i knew that you know once i get some
weight on me then i can optimize so i
cut out the dairy
definitely felt better
i was very particular with spices but i
did use them
and just i just stayed away from the
high oxalate ones
so yeah okay so i want to get into the
lamb thing in a minute but um what about
your experience getting off of
medication
that was
horrendous uh the clonazepam was the
worst i was down to like
16th of a pill and i couldn't let it go
at that point you know it could all be
in my head
but i
i was
it was mania
um i was engaged and i broke up with my
fiance i couldn't i was a different
person i was a monster
and
my parents
i was such a monster that when i moved
back in with my parents
at a certain point they were like you
have to take this because we can't
tolerate you unless you take it
um i was just a wreck and so when you
hold on so when you came off of
everything you had mania
when i was coming off of clonazepam
specifically okay when i yeah the other
ones were fine
yeah when i had yeah adderall what was
your experience getting off of adderall
like it was fine i mean it was an energy
thing but i already felt like crap so
it's like okay whatever
okay so from my experience i i i kind of
had the same thing so when i
when i was on opiates then i had opiate
withdrawal and i went off way too fast
and that was definitely uncomfortable um
but adderall was no issue
um actually i i got off of it once i was
healthier so i didn't even have any
rebound fatigue and i've been taking it
like pretty solidly
for
not for years but maybe a year and a
half and and i'd grown a tolerance too
um but
getting off of it was was easy
ssris completely screwed me over dirty
grill from somebody else's steak would
set me off from like ssri
withdrawal symptoms which were just
horrifying and i've heard like ssri
withdrawals bad but my dad experienced
clonazepam withdrawal and that's a
totally different monster so
there's like a second
wind of withdrawals from clonazepam
because i've worked with other people
who are coming off of them
like i thought i was in the clear for
like a year
and then all of those same symptoms came
back
um
it's crazy it was horrible so yeah
jesus well i hope that doesn't happen
here with my um when i went off of ssris
i went off of them in just two weeks
because i didn't my depression seemed to
have gone away and i was like i don't
need these anymore nobody told me that
they could have
serious withdrawal and i'd been on them
for 11 years and um
that's when i went like hallucinating
crazy with carbs
and then
and then once i got better i had a
period of hypomania for
about a year and a half
which and i didn't even know at the time
until it stopped
i was like oh okay yeah that's the worst
part
yeah you don't realize
you're going crazy
it's horrible yeah everyone around you
so i like you said you were getting off
of clanazepam and you had mania and so
people around you were telling you
how you were being and you're like no
this is just me you just don't like me
for who i am i had that with getting off
of accessorize in a very unpleasant way
i ended up um separating from my husband
if you and that's not just
yeah yeah i mean i i broke i shouldn't
have broken up with him i was in love
and that you know he has a kid now he's
with someone else and it's just crazy
like god has a plan but
i lost so many friendships and
relationships during that time and
um
now i can look back and see i was i was
a [ __ ]
you know i was a monster and
no one understood the nightmare that i
was going through so it gives me a lot
of empathy
yeah yeah me too and if anyone's
listening like i know it sounds like a
good excuse right which i'm sure you've
heard but it sounds like a good excuse
to blame a drug even though it's
literally a drug but um if you go to rx
isc
like risk rxesk.org
um that links to a whole bunch of
stories about psych meds about people
even just starting an antidepressant and
then
getting manic you know going to start a
new family type of thing and the doctor
their doctor i believe his name's david
healey
um specializes in court cases from
people who have gone nuts on
automatically wow
yeah yeah david healey it's a really big
problem that people aren't aware of and
some of these
seemingly innocuous you know drugs like
ssris can cause some serious
problems um
to get into this lamb thing okay so when
i went to all beef i went to beef
because
there were a number of reasons one
it seemed to be the most tolerable thing
i could eat and at the time i hated lamb
so i didn't even try lamb
um and then there was the carnivore
community and i was like
beef seems to be the thing so i started
beef and i did heal on beef but i got c
difficile which i think i had had but
you know you lose part of your you lose
your carb-consuming bacteria when you go
carnivore and if you're on a high fat
diet c diff if you have an overgrowth
already can flourish so then i had a
gift yeah so i had c diff for like a
year and a half and it took me 10 months
to figure out what it was
because you're only supposed to get c
diff if you go on a whole bunch of
antibiotics which i'd been on
but
it was the switch into the zero carb
diet that really did it so i was healing
from all these things and i was having
this c diff anyway i ended up getting
rid of it
by doing
fmt although i had to
take the like oral capsules to hit the
small intestine but antibiotics didn't
work however i have found um because i
have a group on facebook i have found a
lot of people who switch over to the
beef diet
do a lot better especially if they have
gut problems specifically
on
lamb
and it doesn't make even veal can be a
little bit better but lamb seems to be
like if you've got serious gut damage
and
your gut isn't handling particularly
beef fat
fatty lamb is really worth a try because
i can do
like i've i had a very damaged gut and i
managed to to do
all beef um and then started
incorporating lamin and was like oh i'm
feeling better but it didn't occur to me
that it was the lamb making me feel
better too
and so i do like i can do dried cuts of
beef super easily i can have jerky i can
have
dried meat i can have leaner cuts
depending on it
but for the fatty cuts like
i'm pretty much lamb now and that seems
to be optimal for me
um beef and lamb sausages that seems
fine but i feel ya on the
on the um
lamb and so if anyone's listening and
they're like
well like you're gonna have to try
things out especially if you're really
really really sick because
it's really complicated so like
poke around try different things and
what i've been telling people recently
is hey if you tried all beef and like
you're feeling okay maybe but your
digestion is a mess or maybe it's not
working
yeah i mean lamb i noticed the same
thing with the whole gut thing but also
i think that the amino acid profile
makes a difference if you look up the
amino acid profile in beef versus
chicken versus lamb they're all
different
and these different amino acids really
play a role in our mood
lamb i know has a decent amount of
phenylalanine and that's one of the
things that i supplemented when i was
getting off of adderall
um it's very supportive for mood and i
noticed definitely mood differences even
between the two
but as far as digestion for sure it
makes a big difference i don't know you
know and then histamine issues also lamb
yeah and
they're both smaller smaller process so
lots of perks with lamb
okay so you said you were you were using
dairy you used that to gain weight
and to make things hyper palatable that
makes sense to me um
you said egg yolks do you still eat egg
yolks and butter
i do but not every day um and i'm
actually totally fine
totally i love them but if i
the last time i tried doing butter every
day i did start feeling kind of achy um
but i just listen to my body now like
every seven to 14 days i'm like i need
to eat
a ton
and
i've eaten you know a stick of butter i
ate two sticks of butter on christmas
and i was totally totally good the next
day i felt phenomenal but if i did that
every day i would feel it i would feel
achy so i do mostly be sue it as my fats
eggs i to both sue it
shoes beefs to it and you don't have a
problem with beef suet just the like
fattier cuts
um no yeah exactly i do find with the
beef fat i think it has a lot to do with
i'm actually eating lambs to it right
now but i do okay with beef to it but i
think it depends on where i'm getting it
because i've gotten beefs to it from a
butcher and i had issues
but i'm getting it from a local farmer
who i
freaking love everything i get from them
i don't react to and i just feel like
people need to find
that place that they can rely on
that's very interesting
i just switched over to and i was like
this works better i didn't really think
about it than that like i i don't know
histamine fatty cuts i was like because
i tried like grass-fed i tried different
versions and it was like if it was a
certain amount of fat or a certain
amount of aged which is the problem with
going to restaurants and i don't do well
with it yeah i don't do i don't do well
with aged either but then there are some
people like my my dad who went on the
diet and he'd steak and he's like he
hasn't
he hadn't he had an issue with actual
medication
but digestive wise and with weight and
with mood before this freaking
clonazepam um he was fine with beef but
my mom and i had c difficile
and your mom did too
yeah we both did
oh wow
like i haven't talked to
tons of people who ended up with c diff
when they went over there's a couple of
people who've reached out
um
and i do that's why i talk about it
being like you know if you have that my
gut was totally [ __ ]
before the diet and i'd been on
antibiotics like i took antibiotics
continually this one called dap zone for
my rash and dabstone is like
it's true it's used to treat um
what's that
what's that disease where your like
limbs fall off
oh my gosh i don't know it's it's used
to treat that so it's a serious
antibiotic so my gut is already messed
up but i didn't have c diff until
i switched over although it was worth it
because my arthritis went away and my
mood got better
and you know my skin got better and all
those things but it's definitely
complicated um you on your instagram and
your facebook
you do like one-on-one counseling for
people right
yeah i so i became a certified life and
health coach
um and i love it so
i don't just work with people to help
them do the carnivore diet i work with
people to
identify the interference
and to come up with a way of eating that
is sustainable i want people to have
this intuition that i have developed i
don't want people to feel like they are
going to have to pay someone again in
the future
like once you become left insensitive
you heal your hormones
and you address your behaviors that
could be holding you back there's so
much more to it like environment
behaviors habits
that play into being healthy and being
able to make
good decisions as far as nutrition
so it's really really amazing to work
with people and see
incredible things happen in a fairly
short amount of time
um
it's awesome yeah
okay well that's that's really cool i'm
glad that you've taken like that entire
catastrophe and
trying to turn it into something that
makes that kind of suffering worth it
because otherwise how do you wrap your
head around going through something like
that exactly
totally it's like therapy yeah
yeah okay well um
to anybody listening i think you should
uh check out where where where can
people find you
taylor kato health um on instagram i'm
all my links are on instagram
taylor keto health on facebook
um
and yeah just find me on instagram i'm
most active there and if instagram shuts
down i have other links in that link
tree so you can find me there
okay well i'll link those all below and
in show notes but um
i think it's a main takeaway like
figuring out that intuition
is so important and for people who have
been on medication for decades
it's completely gone because you're told
you're told the entire time to ignore
what you're feeling oh my stomach hurts
oh i have a rash oh it's your anxiety
it's in your head so then you dampen
down everything you're like it's in my
head it's in my head until it's so
obvious that it's not in your head
hopefully that you get out of that and
then you have to re-learn how to trust
your body and once you can trust your
body you can pretty much like you've
done identify what you can eat what you
can't eat
so
it's a lot about that i'm really happy
to see like you look fantastic
and um nobody deserves to go through
that kind of stuff
so i'm really glad you're feeling better
and i'm glad you're doing what you're
doing yeah thanks for helping me along
the way i remember you you told me about
those oral fecal transplants did you do
that
i bought the capsules and then i
was in the hospital and i got better i
still have them
how did you get better
the carnivore diet
and did you do it with lamb
and like eggs
yeah
no egg whites
and dairy yeah yeah and i put out dairy
you know and i felt way better when i
did but my gut is it's so good like
yeah okay that's okay well we'll do a
little bit more chatting um so when i
had when i had c diff and i had symptoms
if i had
salad when i reintroduced salad
my digestion was fine
and i was like
what the [ __ ] is going on like if it was
or maybe
yeah
i mean that's as best a that's as good
as a guess as i have or
feeding
other bacteria that were keeping it in
check like i don't know but i was like
what what am i supposed to do here
if the salad gives me an autoimmune
disorder and no salad means i have this
bacterial infection and like i got rid
of it but
it was not easy it took a while so if
you can do it with diet that would have
been better and i can see how dairy
would have played into that because
dairy also helps you grow other
microbes that could potentially keep it
in shack and things
but
i didn't have that option with the
arthritis dairy was just like
destroying my life
yeah but that's fantastic you got in
check with diet well
check out tailored keto health
if you want some
one-on-one
but thank you very much for sharing your
story and coming on
thank you i really appreciate it thanks
for all that you do
[Music]
kelly hogan welcome to my podcast hey
michaela thanks for having me
i'm very excited to talk to you you have
been doing the carnivore diet for how
long um i just had my 11 year
anniversary in october
wow okay so i wanted to bring a couple
of people on to talk about their
experiences with the diet to give people
who
aren't
familiar with the diet a bit of an idea
of what it's like for people who've been
doing it for a while
so could we start off with you just
giving a brief background about
why you started the diet in the first
place
yeah so i was always a pretty heavy set
kid mine did start
it was a little bit of health and a
little bit of weight issues but i was
always just
heavyset i had a very skinny brother and
a mom with a bombshell gorgeous figure
and my dad was always fairly overweight
and growing up i constantly heard oh she
looks like her daddy and they were nice
yeah i know and and i wanted so much to
look like my mom my gorgeous mom and
feature-wise i did but i was just i was
just a big girl
and in high school i was able to sort of
starve myself down i would eat one
little tiny like lean cuisine meal
per day that was it
and then sometimes as a treat i would
drink a carnation instant breakfast and
i really
i was able to get thinner
but it was not sustainable i was so
hungry and eventually as most dieters do
we'd start eating again gain it all
weight
gain it all back
i was never
anorexic and i was never a binger but i
definitely had disordered eating where i
would just try so hard to starve and i
would i would get in my head oh if i
just ran more so i would go out and run
crazy hours of the night when i would
accidentally
like binge on junk and i thought i was
doing the right thing by avoiding fat
because my my mom thought fat was the
problem um
i think she would buy fat free treats
fat-free cookies for our house because
she never said this to me but i always
knew that she would be happier if i
wasn't so fat
it sounds so mean to say out loud my mom
is an amazing mom but i and i was
probably projecting some of that onto
her
but
it didn't work um fat-free things are
also very high in sugar and so i
continued to just get bigger and bigger
until
i married my high school sweetheart and
when we got married my wedding dress was
a 22-24
and i still gained more after that in
the next couple of years i hit 260
pounds
and i had started then having more of
the health concerns that came with what
i didn't realize was inflammation so i
think
my primary issue was obesity and
inflammation
and i started getting repetitive boils
which my husband cannot even stand to
hear the word boil it bothers him so
much but we were together at the time so
he remembers so i don't blame him for
having a real aversion to that word
but it would start with um you know a
bump on my backside and then it would
get bigger and i would have to go to the
doctor and he would have to lance it
drain it pack it with gauze
antibiotics staph infections and it just
kept happening i was in my early 20s
and and i at first thought it had to do
something with hygiene like what am i
doing wrong so i would change up soaps
and try to shower more and i didn't know
what was wrong with me
and i was also just dealing with the
fact that i was a newlywed that felt
very unattractive my husband did not
have a weight problem and i did and i i
didn't want to be seen without clothes
even in our house i was just i was a
little bit of a mess i like confidence
and then
having these boils on my butt did not
help well by i don't know tenth trip to
see my doctor
he was a very old guy now he's in his
80s
and he said well miss hogan and he was
looking at my chart and i guess reading
the many times he had to do this
i suspect we'll just keep doing this
until one of us dies
and i was
you know i started to get teary
and man i know he was
he was pretty hardcore and i said and i
know i don't well in my mind i was
hoping it would be him first but only
because he was pretty old
but i said i know i don't know what to
do and he said you need to lose at least
100 pounds well then i really cried
because that's that's all i had wanted
of course was to lose weight i it was a
lifelong i said i've tried i've tried i
don't know what to do
and he said it's the carbohydrates he
knew
oh he knew he he proceeded to tell me
about the inuit indians at this point
woke right
wow and that was actually yeah so lucky
that was 16 years ago now
i was i'm now about to turn 42 you look
fantastic thank you um i feel really
good i feel so much better at 41 than i
did at 21 at 21 i was a mess i really
was
and so he's telling me about these
annuit indians and how it's the
carbohydrates and i said i really don't
even know what a carbohydrate is
you know 16 years ago i think that's
forgivable and he said well have you
heard of the atkins diet and said i have
he's like okay well you need more than
that
and
like atkins isn't going to cut it for
you sister
he told me eat all the meat you want
and
i said like how many calories and he
said i don't care as long as you're not
eating anything else
and i said like nothing else and he
he said you know leafy greens won't kill
you
and i said okay but like
that's pretty much it and then he said
eggs cheese
but mostly meat
isn't that crazy that was 2000
2004
yeah 2004 this guy knew
and so he said i'll see you in a year
and up until that point i had been
coming much more often than that so i
thought well that's very optimistic
thinking that was the last boil i've
ever had was the day i was there for
that
um i came back one year later i had lost
80 pounds
and he didn't even know who i was
sitting in the waiting room he looked at
my chart he said ms hogan i said yes and
he said what did you do and that's what
i did
i
i just mostly ate meat and at that point
some some green vegetables
he said no one ever listens to me
he was shocked i said well they should
it was amazing
so for five years i followed that advice
um and i was also working out a lot and
i did lose a lot of weight almost
carnivore almost carnivore
um and then in 2009 at the end of that
five years i was tired and i was kind of
hungry because i was not eating fatty
meat
again i didn't have a book to go on i
just basically was basing all of this on
what this old doctor had told me and for
five years i went with that
and then at the end of five years i
thought do i have to eat these leafy
greens because i didn't really love them
i was feeling pretty good but i really
just wanted to eat meat so i googled is
it safe to just eat meat
and the first thing that i saw was a
group called zeroing in on health it was
not a facebook group it was a forum of
journals with a few hundred people there
who were total carnivores
it was run by charles washington and all
of these people had felt bad
had discovered sort of on their own that
eliminating this and this and this and
that they had already come to this
conclusion that they felt their best
just eating animal
foods and even i was like
for real this is a thing i had no idea i
thought i was almost doing something
wrong for that few years but it was
working for me so i just kept doing it
and then in 2009 that was october i felt
like i had just i found my tribe
and i've been friends with them ever
since we talked and now that group has
moved to facebook and the tribe has
grown much larger because it turns out i
wasn't a freak and that you aren't a
freak it it's a thing
a lot of foods in modern diet are making
people sick
and they're making people
fat and making people inflamed and
autoimmune flare-ups and we're told that
those are the healthiest foods until you
cut them out and you realize
oh no that wasn't healthy for me it was
that was my problem yeah those were the
problem
and of course ever since then i've i've
found out that the entire world hasn't
realized this and that it sounds
completely nuts to most people
um but then i've also the group now um
that zeroing in on health group was now
about 31 000 people and that in the
carnivore world is still not a huge
group because it's a fairly strict
carnivore group and there are some that
are more like carnivore-ish or ketovor
that are massive because obviously that
encompasses you know more people are
open to that so even with a pretty
strict carnivore group
31 000 people who have now said wait i
feel better eating this way too
so that's been pretty reassuring and
also these people that i first found in
2009
they not only look better than their
before pictures at that point but to see
them now 11 years later feeling better
looking better still preaching the same
message for the people who need to hear
it i think that it does bring a lot of
assurance to people so i try to
stay visible as well it's not like um
you can just pop up and decide i want to
tell people that it helped for 11 years
like it takes 11 years of living it to
get there
and and i think i think it's important
for folks to see this isn't just
something that's going to help you for a
couple of years until you go back to
eating all of the things
like for me
this is just
how i feel my best eating and how i plan
to continue eating and how i honestly
think
i
am intended to eat
period
okay
the reason i wanted to interview you
specifically was was for a couple of
reasons one you've been doing it for 11
years and a lot of people say oh well
maybe it'll make you feel bit better at
the beginning but then you'll become
nutrient deficient over time and it's
not going to work out and
clearly there are long-term carnivores
and that isn't the case but the other
reason was because you've had
pregnancies on the diet so i wanted to
just
get a little bit of information about
how those went and whether or not you
stayed on the diet during the
pregnancies
yeah so during that five years of very
low carb i was working out so hard and
not eating much fat and that for a lot
of women is a recipe for not having a
cycle anymore so i stopped having a
period during that time for two years
my husband and i by that point had been
married for several years we wanted kids
i wanted to be a mom so badly
so one of the reasons i started
searching
is it safe to eat meat was partly
because i thought you know i looked i
was looking the way i wanted to look and
i was not getting boils but i was not
able to have children
um yeah and i thought maybe
yeah maybe that was part of the problem
was the eating of meat well this group
that i found they said
it's probably your lack of fat and the
fact that you were working out cardio
two hours per day i was doing cardio an
hour every morning an hour every night
but you need some rest and some fatty
meat it's like fatty meat he didn't tell
me fatty meat he just the doctor had
just said meat all right
so i switched to like their version
of mostly i ate exclusively fatty beef
when i started and i did um no
seasonings at all period not even salt
at first because that's just what they
did and i felt
amazing i instantly felt better
it did take me several months to get my
cycle back but then i immediately got
pregnant
so that was all sort of part of what
helped me to get pregnant so when i did
get pregnant i didn't suddenly think
i should stop this diet like yeah that
there was a part of me because i did
have an ob gyn who was kind of like you
should be eating the rainbow
but eating the rainbow i just had to
keep reminding reminding myself didn't
help me get this baby right eating the
rainbow
was not the solution
and so charles washington who ran the
group he said
you know that your fetus
is just a little tiny version of you
right just a little tiny human in there
and if eating meat was so good for you
you have to imagine it's probably good
for
him or her too
well that that makes sense so i had just
a tiny bit of doubt but i think it was
mostly coming from just everything i had
ever heard about a pregnancy diet how
you should eat so much fiber you know or
else you'll end up with
hemorrhoids and constipation and all
those issues okay so once i kind of hush
that little tiny voice and remember no
eating meat got you here
stick with it
i did have some meat aversions during
the first trimester of all three
pregnancies where the sight of raw meat
was very off-putting
um so i had to do a lot of for me eggs i
can tolerate eggs so i ate a lot of
scrambled eggs and bacon and sausage
sort of like soft core carnivore
and that was able to work for me and i
did use some hot sauce because there
were times where the taste of meat
wasn't even appealing
yeah but i never i did not go back to
carbs i did stay fully carnivored for
all three pregnancies minus
two very small i only mention this not
because it matters nutritionally i just
think in the name of being transparent
and honest
with my first pregnancy i was having an
incr like insane craving for pickles
so i gave in and ate some pickles
and then it passed and i was right back
to it i do not think that disqualifies
me as a carnivore i just i had a moment
of weakness michaela and i gave in to
the pickles oh man who can't who can who
can deny pickles though and sometimes
that's that's a real thing that need of
pickles and then when i was pregnant
with my youngest child annie she is now
four and a half i i tried some peanuts
because i just they were screaming for
me and we have peanuts here at my house
how did that go
oh not good um i got very itchy in like
some weird places
like immediately um they did they did
still taste good to me but immediately
my reaction was oh my gosh okay that
can't be good and so i i stopped that
other than those two things yes it was
all meat eggs limited dairy i can handle
a little dairy but
i don't have to be quite as extreme as
you but i cannot eat much cheese or i
get some
acne weight gain
extreme cravings for more even though it
doesn't make me feel my best and
anything that makes me want more that
does not make me feel awesome
you know i'm wearing morning right yes
morning
yeah okay so we covered you had three
successful pregnancies on the carnivore
diet your version of the carnivore diet
that you've been doing and you've been
doing it for these you had these boils
and you had
weight gain
uh and you had massive weight loss
and it's
mainly
meat and a little bit of dairy and eggs
yeah yes
primarily beef about once a week i go to
my father-in-law's house and he likes to
cook pork chops and ribs and so i can
and he seasons his food with spices not
sauces and i can handle all of that but
my day-to-day life
i do not mind monotony and i just love
the way beef tastes and the way i feel
when i eat it so i mostly just eat beef
yeah okay great and you've been doing it
for 11 years and you haven't become
vitamin deficient no and i do go for
blood work every year
i know some carnivores have stopped
going because they said you know it's
ridiculous it's the same every single
year and they feel great
but i i like to share those numbers
yearly because i think people want to
feel better yeah
it even still makes me feel better i
want a doctor to say nope no
deficiencies everything looks good you
know i know that i'm sleeping well so i
don't have an r ring but i can't measure
some of these things
you know some carnivores measure
everything they've got a ring to measure
they're sleeping they've got a patch to
measure measure their glucose i'm not
really that into measuring stuff i've
never checked my ketones i i don't know
i'm just not that interested in checking
all of the things but
i do feel some reassurance from the
doctor telling me that i'm not deficient
in that all of my numbers look good i
recently went this year for my 11-year
carniversity to have a cac test done oh
yeah and it measured at a perfect zero i
think all of that information is
reassuring to myself and to anybody
who's say you know has that doubt that
eating meat is going to somehow cause me
to die of a heart attack just say look
it's been 11 years they found nothing
the woman doing the scan of of my heart
for the cardia
calcium artery score she said there's
nothing it's a zero
which is you know obviously the goal for
those who aren't familiar with the test
zero was good and i would like to
continue doing that because that is a
radiation type test i probably won't do
that every year but if every five years
i could say i'm still not dead still not
dead
i think
i think that's probably a good thing for
anyone who's pessimistic you certainly
don't look dead one more question i
think when you first so you went to you
kind of did what i did which is i went
low carb and then i went to meat and
greens and then
i still had lingering symptoms and was
like is it even possible to drop the
greens or am i getting all my
vitamins from the greens and then i went
to the meat diet so when you went
from this you standard you went from
standard american diet to meat and
greens right
yeah my version of low carb was really
strict low carb so yeah basically just
meat and greens and like pickles green
vegetables yeah yeah mine too um did you
have transition symptoms or difficulty
doing that and then did you have
transition or difficulty just dropping
and going to meet
i had i did not have difficulties with
either one wow i know when i see people
struggle so much with just dropping
carbs now what i did have was crazy
addiction withdrawals like the shakes
even okay i missed i missed sugar so
much mental and physical i craved sugar
like crazy for a couple of weeks so yes
that was very hard but you know some
people have like what they call oxalate
dumping and
rashes the keto flu i did not experience
any of that i just really missed sugar
yeah and then when i gave up the last
little bit of plants when i switched in
2009
the only issue i had then was
about 20 pounds of weight gain
for about six months really slowly
gained about 20 pounds when i first went
carnivore and if you if you had met me
at that point when i first met the
carnivores it would make so much sense i
again i was avoiding all fat by the end
of that five years of very low carb i
was
i was
so strict with meat and a tiny bit of
greens but i was not allowing fatty
meats it was like skinless chicken
breast because that was coming back from
childhood of thinking fat was bad still
and without having a book like judy
chose carnivore cure to say fat is good
no one was telling me that i didn't have
any voice in my head telling me that fat
was okay
um
so i was going from very low calorie
very low fat super extreme workouts to
then boom now you're going to eat all
the fatty meat you want and you're not
going to go to a gym because you want to
have a baby
yeah i gained some weight at first and
and i've seen that happen with people
your body becomes almost like a hoarder
for a little bit a hoarder of nutrition
because you are i was malnourished i
didn't look like a typical malnourished
person
but i do believe i was
nourished and had rabbit starvation i
was having mental fog
and just struggling to have energy
because i was not properly fueled
and so yeah i think my body really
grasped onto that and for about six
months i was insanely
insatiably
hungry
and i was eating um
maybe not twice as much as i need to eat
now but probably close yeah and then at
about the six month mark it was like
okay oh i could i actually feel pretty
good on just like two pounds of meat per
day versus three to three and a half
and it's not that i purposefully stopped
eating his butt i don't think i could
have i was so hungry i don't have that
much willpower i don't think i could
have stopped
with that much hunger before but once my
appetite relaxed it's like i just my
body took a breath
and then i felt
i felt full enough and fueled and i was
able to just eat like kind of a normal
carnivore
if that's a thing a normal carnivore a
normal carnivore when i uh when i
dropped it yeah when i first went to low
carb so i did similar
at the beginning i had things like sweet
potatoes and a little bit of apple as
well as meat and greens and then i went
to meat and greens but throughout that
entire period especially the first two
years of going low carb i ate so much it
was unbelievable switching from standard
american diet i still lost weight i
still lost weight but i switched over to
low carb and i
i don't know how i could have possibly
been that hungry but i'm sure that i was
trying to my body was trying to get
nutrients i hadn't been absorbing
properly or something um and then when i
switched to i was breastfeeding when i
switched to carnivore so i ate like
three and a half pounds of food a day
yes but i actually lost weight going
from meat and greens to just meat i lost
it was probably water at the beginning
but i lost 15 pounds in the first month
and then kind of stabilized and then the
reason i started incorporating fasting
in was because there was
about 10 pounds that i that was
didn't feel right and i was like why
like why isn't it going away and fasting
felt good but that was way after i was
done breastfeeding um and i don't really
do it anymore it was like a year and i
think i had stored this is my theory i
don't know if it's real but i think i
had old stored fat
that wasn't very healthy
okay
um because
people use fat cells to store toxins
um so i think i had kind of unhealthy
fat stores and wanted to get rid of it
because
the first couple times fasting i did not
feel good and then i started feeling
better and better and better so that's
my theory with fasting but
um thank you very much for coming on and
like i said i wanted to do a brief
segment with a couple of people
to
get a bit of a background on people who
do the carnivore diet oh one thing i
wanted to add actually is from what i've
seen was speaking to people people who
are generally speaking fairly healthy
but have
extra weight
don't seem to have as much of a hard
time transitioning in as people who have
autoimmune disorders specifically or who
are really really really ill
and some of those people they get
rashes
diarrhea
fatigue muscle cramps like their entire
body just goes
wonky for you know at least six weeks um
so it's night but then there are some
people who they just switch over and
they're like oh i have more energy and i
feel better yep um yeah that was much
more me especially other than that
weight gain i mean i probably wouldn't
have put up with 20 pounds of weight
gain because that was incredibly
difficult for me mentally to see that
scale go back up but i felt so good i
just that fog had lifted and my energy
was back
obviously i'd already stopped having the
boils that was not the issue that that
was already with almost carnivore that
had stopped but i just felt so renewed
that i stuck with it and also i had this
goal of i wanted to be pregnant
and you know i had this whole group
right there in my ear telling me all the
time if you want something different you
have to do something different you could
go right back to all that restricting
and low fat and lose that little bit of
weight but after several months i lost
that 20 pounds very quickly and and then
i was able to just easily maintain
weight ever since then so that's been 10
and a half years at
this same weight pregnancies aside
obviously that fluctuated some
um and i haven't had to stress about it
since but i think that that refeed
period where my body was starving like
yours was too i think it was very
important i don't think that's rushed
yeah i agree and if you didn't have your
period too then your body was trying to
get something so it may have been
sucking in all the nutrients and been
like kind of in panic mode we need to
store fat and then once you've been
doing it for a while it was like okay
maybe this is unnecessary that'd be my
yeah uneducated guess yeah i like it i
love uneducated guesses by people who
have lived something right like that's
how it felt to me also and i was the one
living it i can't back it up with
anything but that's how it felt
yeah well thank you very much kelly um
where can people find you online because
kelly has some really amazing groups for
people
starting the diet
or interested in carnivore diet and it
makes it much much much less isolating
if you join some of those groups if
you're even if you're just interested in
learning more so where can people find
you online youtube
is my zero carb life z-e-r-o and i have
a lot of carnivores on it is just a
carnivore channel
and then
zeroing in on health if you type that in
on facebook search that's the facebook
group where i help to add men but most
of my day-to-day like just talking about
what it's like to be a carnivore and
just sharing videos in my life is that
instagram kelly underscore hogan91
perfect thanks very much
thank you
[Music]
emily penton welcome to my podcast
hi thanks for having me
well i'm excited to talk to you i've
been watching a bit of your journey
which has been
incredible honestly unbelievable if i
was looking at it from the outside which
i am but i've kind of been there so i
kind of know what it's like
but um i'm going to start off with
asking you similar questions to
the other questions i've asked other
people
so one
why did you start
doing the all meat diet
um i started because i had debilitating
mental illness
um i had bipolar bipolar disorder that
turned into rapid cycling
um which
bipolar can be you know you have a good
couple of years and then you have some
bad years you can have good months and
then bad months mine went into every
single day i didn't know who i was gonna
be
um it was like i was two different
people and either i was up and able to
function or i was in bed and completely
unable to function
um and so i
learned through um you know researching
the carnivore diet
that um
there was a possibility
that other people had resolved their
bipolar disorder
symptoms
with eating only meat and so i just
jumped right in i was so miserable
i was in such a dark dark place
that um
nothing was
too out there i i was already taking
900 milligrams of lithium 80 milligrams
of adderall just to get out of bed every
day
80 milligrams of prozac um and then
ambient to sleep every night to
counteract that adderall
so
i feel like that was extreme so i was
willing to talk you feel like that was
an extreme yeah i i was taking
i wasn't 80 milligrams of adderall jesus
i was taking 40 milligrams of adderall
and i went to 50 because i started to
get used to the 40. i was like oh [ __ ] i
can't stay awake and i went to 50 and
was just like i can't keep doing this
it's way too hard i cannot even imagine
what being like 80.
i can't imagine 80 milligrams i would
take 40 i would take 40 before i would
even get out of bed
yeah like that's what i did i couldn't
get on a set yeah
and then i would take 40 at noon
and then of course i had to have ambien
at night so that i could sleep because i
had 88 milligrams of adderall all day
so
why like what did you see that convinced
you even to try it
um i
my brother sent me the um
first book chapter of the audiobook by
ambro hearn
um and i just listened to her first
chapter um and i remember i was just
laying in the bathtub and i had it on my
phone it was on audiobook
and
all i could do was just lay there and
listen to it and something resonated in
me and i i really can't explain it but
there was a knowing
i i there was a knowing that i knew that
whatever she had gone through for some
reason this worked for her and that it
was possible that's all i needed was
that it was possible
that this could work for me
and i was willing to try and so i jumped
in the next day i went from the standard
american diet to
only
meat and fat
animal meat and animal fat the next day
and i didn't turn back
okay and then um i haven't read amber's
book to be honest i know she suffered
from bipolar and i i learned about her a
number of months after i started the
carnivore diet
um but
what what was the transition like going
from the standard american diet to the
carnivore diet
yeah the first week i felt like i had
kind of the flu but um i what i didn't
know was that i already had an
underlying condition of multiple
sclerosis
um and so i already felt like crap um my
joints ached um uh i was just
had complete brain fog
um and i didn't know at that time when i
actually started this i started this
february 24th of 2019
um
that that that was what was really going
on um but the first week i felt like i
had the flu um i was nauseous
um headache sore
irritable and then as i went into the
second and third week
i started feeling better but i still had
those cravings for sugar and everything
but once i got to the end of the fourth
week
um i experienced joy
and the joy was all i needed just to
just to know what that felt like to
experience that glimpse of joy
um was all i needed to just keep going
and then i um
my cravings resolved and that's what
shocked me because i don't have a lot of
like willpower i'm not this like healthy
guru person at all
and it was a piece of cake
funny
but it was very easy
once i ate enough animal fat once i had
enough bacon or sausage
or any kind of animal fat i was fine
okay so you're on
a number of medications did you have
trouble getting off of them
um no i didn't attempt to take uh to get
off of any of my medications until my
psychiatrist recognized that i was doing
so well
um so i didn't taper off my meds until
july
so i started february 24th i didn't
start tapering off until july and i my
last med was september 2019.
okay so you had a psychiatrist that
maybe knew what they were doing
yes and he said you know emily there's
light in your eyes and he's he's been
with me for uh eight almost 10 years now
what did what did he think about the
fact you were only eating mead
um he
didn't really have much to say about
that particularly he just kept saying i
can see a difference
i can see a difference and i was able to
get through my sessions without crying
you know without like uh you know like
being this bumbly mess
and he was just and then when i started
working in june of 2019 i started
working full-time
um and i hadn't worked full-time for a
while
um and so that was huge to him as well
and then he
decided he was just like okay i think
you're ready
and i was like huh i was like no like
the meds are my security blanket i can't
we just be happy that i'm functioning
and he was like yeah but we can tape her
off and so we tapered really slowly
off and um i still see him every two
months just to make sure
yeah well that's fair and be a little
bit concerned you don't want to drop
back into insanity no
people who don't know what that's like
don't understand how horrible that is
yeah
okay
physical transition you had a massive
i've seen your before and after pictures
and they're huge so can you describe for
people who don't know who you are can
you describe what happened physically
yeah that was um
really a nice side effect um but it
wasn't my intention i liked being a big
girl
and i didn't see anything wrong with my
body
i didn't realize how sick i was
um i had no idea how much inflammation i
had um and i'm i'm grateful now that for
the weight loss and
losing the inflammation but i was at 240
pounds
um i'm five eight
uh and it started going off i mean
immediately it was almost a pound a day
it was crazy
um and so i started at 2 40 on february
24th 2019 and by
um december of 2019 i was at 135
um and so and i've kept it off i've i've
i'm still at 130 135.
okay so part of the reason i'm doing
this specific episode is because
the trend like
even just hearing the transformation
from my perspective and i'm literally on
the same diet and i've had
somewhat of a similar transformation it
still doesn't sound believable compared
to what you hear it really doesn't sound
believable so i'm trying to give people
a perspective and talk to real people
because this actually happens as insane
that as that is because you wouldn't
think that you could
eat anything and lose that amount of
weight that just doesn't seem possible
no
okay what's your current diet like
um i eat probably about um
eight ounces of
beef
um and it's regenerative beef so it's
like locally
um
grass-fed
beef
um and five ounces of beef fat
so i just order the beef separately
um
and then uh one pound of ground beef
every day so roughly about two pounds
um every day um and i eat first thing in
the morning and that's all i eat i just
eat one meal
you're still only on one meal a day
and i eat it wrong
um
no no
yeah i've eaten how do you like that i
know it's weird okay i've tried that
after you only eat meat for a while
like you try only meat for like a couple
of years and you're like well all these
people are talking about like eating
meat wrong maybe i should try it but
i don't know
well i don't because i coach people um
on eating this way eating carnivore um
and i don't recommend that people start
there at all
that would be way too hard yeah it's
already hard enough that would be way
too hard it wasn't my intention it was a
natural progression my as as i started
this diet i was able to really hear my
body
and i was able to
know what i wanted instead of just
shoving my face with ice cream and pizza
and ramen noodles you know i ramen
noodles
yeah i could really tell what my body
was saying yes too and it was saying yes
to raw fat
so that was the start
and um as i got to the end of my first
year um i tried raw fat and
whenever i i cooked it it felt heavy it
felt like greasy in my stomach okay i
have a question have you tried
so i i i've been doing this diet since
2017
and i did only beef for
years because beef was the one thing
that like made me mentally stable and
physically okay
but my digestion was always
not so good and i talked about that
extensively on joe rogan which is just
something that happened but like it
wasn't good and i about two years later
i realized if i ate lamb it was okay
and that's cooked have you tried
going on a lamb spree
no um i do that and see what happens
because i did that with my mom because
my mom has similar arthritic she doesn't
have any mental thank god for her she
doesn't have any of the mental problems
but she had
osteoarthritis and it was
solved it wasn't solved by going very
low carb with like meat and greens but
it was solved going with just meat but
then she had kind of she has celiac
disease i have celiac disease and she
had digestive issues with all beef even
though her arthritis was gone
and it took like years for me to figure
out lamb worked better i don't know what
it is with beef fat
but b fat seems to be
an issue for people who are only eating
meat which makes the diet seem even more
insane
but i see i see what happened there
because i could eat
cold bee fat i could eat jerky
but like steaks
were hard on the digestive system so you
should try lamb see what happens yeah i
definitely want to try that you've
suggested that and i i'm i'm on the
lookout for a good source
um
but uh
my work around was just to eat the fat
and what i do is i just cut it into tiny
little cubes almost like cheese
just tiny little cubes and then i freeze
it
yeah so i eat it frozen and raw and
salted
um and then i noticed that there were
some pieces of meat still attached to
the fat and then i was able to eat those
and so i was like hmm
this is really easy
i don't have to meal plan i don't have
to how much easier can i make this and
so i pushed the envelope of laziness and
i was like i don't even have to cook
this like this is crazy
and so i tried it raw and i cut it into
little cubes and i freeze it and it is
so easy
okay this is why i i um advertise the
air fryer so so much so i'm like hey you
take a frozen steak you put in the air
fryer and then as the cook steak like
ease
yeah but um when i used to cook ribs
when i was still mostly eating beef when
i used to cook ribs
i'd cook the ribs and then i'd put them
in the fridge because i could eat them
cold made no sense to me none because i
don't understand i don't understand how
cooked beef fat can be different than
cold beef fat yeah it doesn't make sense
to me but um i yeah it doesn't make
sense to me so what i do doesn't make
sense to me either i just know that i
love it i know that i wake up every day
and i cannot wait to eat this and i'm so
excited and i've been eating the exact
same thing for
over a year
um and before that it was only you know
the only addition was chicken and pork
and you know stuff like that can you eat
pork without any like mental side
effects
no it costs you can't do pork i haven't
been able to find a local good source i
think if i found a good source but
eating it out of the grocery store i
couldn't
okay i tried i'm not even um i don't
think i've tried wild boar and maybe
that would be better but i certainly
can't do even high quality sources of
pork
and i haven't been brave enough to try
it in europe because i've heard the
european
pork
can be higher quality and i just haven't
wanted to risk it it gives me arthritis
it gives my mom arthritis
worse than
berries or salad greens it's actually
worse which is weird because it's meat
so it's not only about the fact that
it's meat it's
specific types of meat yeah but what
about chicken how's chicken for you
chicken makes me very irritable i get
really emotional um but then again i
haven't had a chance to find a good
local source so
i've put all of my energy into finding a
good local beef source
beef and beef fat um and so that's my
sweet spot right now um i think i i
eventually will
um
you know experiment a little bit more
but
once you feel good you just want to stay
there for a minute and i feel like my
body is healing more and more every day
so i just want to stay here for a second
no i get that i did i did nothing but b
for two years
and then i added lamb very carefully and
now i know lamb is actually
easier on me than beef which i wish i
had known at the beginning but i didn't
so i would recommend trying lamb but
i certainly can't do pork and chicken i
can only do if it's
bread very carefully and fed the right
food
like very specifically i can do a bit of
wild salmon like there are things i can
do now that don't make me absolutely
insane which is great
but um anyway i'm
i'm really glad you're feeling better
you look great you're very clear
thank you and i did um add
raw milk a month ago
so i have no
eight ounces of raw milk every day and
um that's been the first time in two
years that i've been able to
tolerate milk so that's been really good
and nothing has happened no
and it hasn't affected your skin
i feel better yeah i actually feel
better okay
well that might be i mean there are a
lot of doctors that say you know you go
on a meat diet as crazy as it sounds and
then you heal your gut
and then you incorporate something like
raw milk in order to rebuild the
microbiome
so theoretically that makes sense
i think people with
specifically joint problems depending on
the person i think they can have a very
difficult time with dairy
but
i mean i don't know i can't do it
but i've heard from a lot of people that
that's kind of the next step on gut
healing it's like stop damaging it heal
and then
incorporate raw milk or some sort of
pre or probiotic food to help
grow back all your gut bacteria that
you've lost somehow
yeah so
i i did it really gradually and i was um
i thought about it for like six months
but i just it was this nagging thought
and so i was just like fine i'll try it
you know and i tried it and
um i felt really good so i'm just like
okay well we'll just say fantastic
part of the thing i tell people when
they're trying this diet is
you want to be on the diet you want to
eliminate all your symptoms
and then you want to try and heal
yourself right because
from my from my perspective people are
not supposed to just eat meat forever
you know you're not supposed to eat a
berry and then go crazy that's just
that's an unreasonable thing for a human
being to do so ideally you can heal and
be a little bit more tolerant to things
you could hopefully eat but
good for you
well and i have a lot to lose if the ms
comes back you know because the multiple
sclerosis i mean the bipolar disorder
was terrifying
but then the multiple sclerosis i
couldn't walk without an assist
assistive device
um and i had delayed and slurred speech
and worse brain fog than i did even with
the bipolar
um and so that was terrifying um
and so i i can't go back it's not like i
can just like
you know
it's not like you just gain five pounds
it's like if i go back i'm going back to
mental illness and physical illness that
is i'm not going to tolerate that's not
okay with me
i don't think people who haven't been
there understand
i don't know how you explain it like
even knowing me i wouldn't be able to
explain it my to myself
if i if i hadn't been there i wouldn't
believe it it's too bad right
absolutely and that's why you know
people are like this is a crazy diet but
what's crazier is staying there staying
where i was you know it wasn't an option
yeah right i was so miserable
try being in a wheelchair
yeah
like it's not it's not good and you'd do
anything to get out of it
absolutely
emily thank you very much for coming on
and good for you
and i'm so glad you've been able to
incorporate milk that's cool
keep me posted
if you end up going further than that i
do think people can heal out of this
like i've known people who've been very
very very ill and then they've started
at the like complete bottom with meat
and then they've gone to some sort of i
mean you know you teach people
but
you should be able to like crawl your
way out of this a little bit further so
yeah that's my favorite is whenever i'm
talking to my my clients and everything
and they start to get to that moment
that i got to at 30 days
and they're just like oh my goodness
this is what good feels like and i'm
like yeah and they're like i'm never
going back that's my favorite
conversation that i have with clients
and they're just like i'm doing this
forever and then they don't need me and
i love it
i know that's the point you want to get
some sort of coach where you eventually
don't need them
yes
and i don't want them to rely on me i
want them to just try it get through the
first 30 days 45 days and then it's it
takes over you know and then they know
they have that formula and they know hey
i removed this food and then i
reintroduced it and it was a problem so
yeah they don't have to take dr
so-and-so's advice they know
they know themselves what foods they
react to
and it's just beautiful empowering them
to
to have that knowledge themselves
yeah i completely agree
emily where can people find you online
i'm at carnivore minds on instagram
um or if you want to reach out to me for
coaching you can email me at your
center of brilliance
gmail.com
thank you so much for coming on
no problem
[Music]
you